what's book is Tony Robbins reading now
whatever you write how's the believin
brain which is fascinating it talks
about how our beliefs control our life
control our experience of reality how
its shaped by both biochemistry in your
environment really really great book all
right the believing brain advice one
could say that you give people advice
you get motivation inspiration what's
the best piece of advice you've ever
done have that so much but I think one
of the most important ones was early in
my life one of my mentors men named Jim
Rohn said Tony all you have to focus on
your life is find a way to add more
value than anybody else does and you'll
never have to worry about anything be
the person that does more for others and
life will just be any one thing you want
out of it really is what it is and so
and he also said the way to do that is
every day work harder than yourself
anything else because if you become more
intelligent more valuable more skilled
you can add more value to other people
let's do something a little more prosaic
which is technology apps and show you
that's obviously a avid fan of all this
stuff you have a favorite piece of
technology or a favorite it's different
you might think I do have a very it's a
large piece of technology I had I'm in a
cryotherapy a familiar with it yes so
for people aren't I'm on stage 50 hours
in a weekend I got five ten thousand
people I do 26 and a half miles on one
day starts at 8:30 goes to literally 1
o'clock in the morning I do 22 miles two
days before so if like ultramarathon i
used to ice myself as I did in football
and you know take it ice baths yes yeah
because you have to bring the swelling
down on your body and now I do these
three-minute and nitrogen-filled cases
that you get in it's like a sauna and it
reduces your body temperature to minus
220 Fahrenheit and that sounds like you
freeze to death or you burn if you had
water in your body whose burn you get
third-degree burns but there's no
moisture and it is amazing was it
developed originally for people with
arthritis I got one for my mother-in-law
had all these problems no more arthritis
challenges so I started using it gives
you endorphins it resets your system
it's extraordinary piece of technology
it's expensive but you can go to centers
that are showing up all over the u.s.
mostly athletes the Lakers and so forth
are starting to use